Shawn Mendes dodging that Camilla Kibeho
dating question like a pro but sometimes
silence is louder than you think it all
went down during a fan meet-and-greet
before Shawn took the stage in Dallas
[Music]
Shawn also revealed this about his new
butterfly tattoo I just thank you
and he hinted a documentary might be on
the way
[Music]
working on one
but back to Camilla and Shawn the pair
has been spending a whole lot of time
together lately ever since their steamy
seniorita video came out take a close
look
that's them holding hands up in San
Francisco last week and in this shot
from the same weekend Shawn's got his
arms wrapped around Camilla and of
course there's this video of them
kissing
[Music]
the pair has been hit with romance
rumors for years since 2015 when they
released their first collab at the time
the pair both told ET and nothing
romantic was going on set the record
straight no we are just friends for
edges and we're not dating
yeah we're just friends he's like one of
my best friends he's amazing she's
amazing like super talented his
songwriter like height was so no I mean
I've never worked at the Hyksos
songwriter who I clicked with as well as
her so Jeff
[Music]
[Applause]